Tom Hanks is known as the nicest guy in Hollywood,
but his new novel is about an actor who's kind
of a nightmare. Surprisingly, Hanks says the
character is based at least partially on himself.
That's right: even America's
dad has bad days, apparently.
According to Hanks' new interview
with the BBC, he doesn't always
succeed at being the nicest guy in the
room. While promoting his first novel,
"The Making of Another Major Motion Picture
Masterpiece," Hanks said that the arrogant
actor in the story is partly inspired by some
of his most stressful days on set, revealing,
"I have pulled every single one of those
moments of behavior myself on a set. Not
everybody is at their best every single day on a
motion picture set. I've had tough days trying to
be a professional when my life has been falling
apart in more ways than one and the requirement
for me that day is to be funny, charming
and loving — and it's the last way I feel."
The book focuses on the drama behind the
scenes of a wildly expensive superhero film,
from a megalomaniac director to the aforementioned
difficult actor. The actor constantly keeps
causing delays to the filming with his bad
behavior. Obviously, this is an exaggerated
version of Hanks' real on-set behavior, but in any
case, he's admitting that he isn't always perfect.
"That rug was given to me by the Dalai Lama!
And you sent it in for cleaning?
You're off the picture!"
The Academy Award winner did say there's one
rule he never breaks about on-set behavior.
Unlike the fictional actor in his book,
who struggles with punctuality and causes
problems when he eventually arrives on set, Hanks
makes sure he's never tardy for a shoot. He said,
"What cannot occur on a motion picture is that
someone cannot monkey around with the timing or
the length of the shoot or the budget. That is
a cardinal sin in the motion picture business.
You will be amazed at how many people
know that they can get away with it,
and are told they can get away with it, because
they are carrying the movie on their shoulders."
It's not surprising that someone as established
as Hanks, who has been a major part of the film
and TV industry for decades, has some internalized
rules he'll never break. He's only human, though,
and sometimes his demeanor slips. It's
sometimes for good reason, though. For
example when some fans were chasing Hanks and
his wife Rita Wilson in the summer of 2022,
one tripped Wilson. Hanks was enraged, jumping
to the defense of his wife and shouting,
"Back the f--- off!"
Even with the occasional bad day for Hanks, it
doesn't seem to have translated to him losing
work. He's one of Hollywood's most prominent
and consistently cast actors. Notably,
he won two Oscars in a row for "Forrest Gump" and
"Philadelphia," and he hasn't slowed down since,
working with directors like Steven Spielberg
and Ron Howard regularly. Regarded as one of
the best living actors, Hanks is also one of
the highest-grossing performers working today,
so obviously, directors are willing to
overlook a few bad moments here and there.
In 2022 alone, he appeared in
three high-profile projects — Baz
Luhrrman's biopic "Elvis," his frequent
collaborator Robert Zemeckis' adaptation
of "Pinocchio," and the heartwarming
family flick "A Man Called Otto."
"Do you think I'm going to cut myself, and
bleed all over your floor and sue you?"
He's also dabbled in television
documentaries in the last several years,
producing 2019's "The Movies" and "1968:
The Year That Changed America." He also
worked with "Yellowstone" head honcho Taylor
Sheridan on an episode of the spin-off "1883."
Hanks isn't going anywhere any time soon, and
if you want to check out a dramatized version
of his on-set behavior, "The Making of Another
Major Motion Picture Masterpiece" is out now.